one of the very first auditions I ever
had was with Robert De Niro oh wow
Scorsese what for a movie called Cape
Fear oh yeah that's a great movie yeah I
didn't get it you're not in it
you heard her there once was a time when
even Reese Witherspoon didn't get the
role she wanted stopping by Jimmy Kimmel
Live last week Reese recalled some of
her early auditions and encounters with
A-list Stars I got so scared when I
walked in the room I didn't know who
Robert De Niro was so I was standing
outside I was talking to receptionist
there she was like you know he's the
most important actor of our time oh
great and I was like
I was 14 like what did I I never seen
Good Fellas like I've never seen The
Godfather while the role in Cape Fear
eventually went to Juliette Lewis that
doesn't mean De Niro forgot about Reese
Witherspoon down the road
I auditioned for him 10 years later oh
he did and I thought he was never gonna
remember that I bricked that audition
and he was like I remember you
it's like me he's like oh yeah you're
the one who couldn't say the word and I
was like oh my God this is so bad I know
meanwhile Reese also talked about an
early run-in with another well-known
celebrity did you ever have a job behind
the scenes yeah actually I um I was an
intern on a movie that Denzel Washington
starred in called Devil in a Blue Dress
um whenever Denzel came in I had to park
his Porsche really which is not a good
idea for a 17 year old kid was it a man
transmission driver's license oh my God
I stripped all the gears oh
right Reese I mean but that story
between Reese and Denzel truly came full
circle decades later but the funny story
is is I saw him a few years ago at a
wedding and he's like I've heard you
tell this story about how you used to
park my Porsche and I was like yes I did
and he's like but did you know that your
costumes on Water for Elephants who took
them in and out of your trailer and I
was like no I have no idea he's my
daughter
and I was like that is amazing so there
was like this full circle you should let
her ruin your car